kevin is with us in Connecticut
hi Kevin welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave honored to talk to you thanks
so much for taking my call sure how can
I help okay
so my wife and I are just starting out
on your plan we're really excited about
it just started using every dollar this
month and it looks like we can put about
2,500 to 3,000 towards dead a month good
we have about 28 thousand and debt and
still have about 8,000 in savings that
we were saving to put down on a house
before we found your plan
so with that seven thousand above the
baby step one amount that we have you
were considering paying off our car to
free up a $200 a month payment I just
wanted your thoughts on that if we
should if we could kind of start off
with a bang since we have a little money
in the bank or if we should just do the
traditional step to that snowball the
math won't change right so if we just
keep paying on the car you know it won't
it won't change I mean it changes your
monthly amount that you're freed up but
you will get out of debt at exactly the
same time mathematically that you would
have otherwise so it doesn't matter how
many so you'd have seven thousand is
obviously not your smallest debt then no
it would actually be the last one oh
okay so you got a bunch of little ones
yeah well it's we got about three
thousand credit cards eighteen thousand
student loans but they're all they're
all split up into tiny ones yeah so just
where the car lands is kind of laughs
yeah I got you hmm it's okay if you want
to do it then the thing is I mean I
probably wouldn't I probably would work
the straight debt snowball again
okay the interesting thing is when you
run the mouth out it's going to come out
exactly the same so the only argument
out here is which one gives you the most
jet fuel emotionally right to attack
this stuff with and you know look down
how many of those little ones you could
pay off for seven thousand dollars that
would give me a lot of jet fuel this is
like it's going to be a whole
bunch of your list right mm-hmm did you
got a lot of stuff under a thousand
bucks mm-hmm yeah definitely how many I
mean so it's it's my wife's doing loan I
know it's our 3-month yeah um so I don't
have the breakdown right in front of me
but I think the biggest one is like like
3:30 3200 days no no I'm talking about
that little credit cards cuz you got a
lot of bills yeah under like $1,000 you
got a lot of bills that are player a 300
on one yeah yeah like 300 on one 1,200
on one and then like I don't know 1500
on the other degree knock those out like
right away yeah they'd be done and be
nice to be done credit card free I mean
I don't it doesn't you know it's just
kind of uh which one's gonna give you
guys when you talk it through together
the most the most emotional jet fuel and
because mathematically it's going to
come out I mean within within a penny or
two of the same so doesn't matter of me
I'm probably gonna do that I know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna pay off the
little ones cuz I like the idea of
getting rid of a whole bunch of stuff on
the list rather than one thing on the
list that just that would give me more
boost the way my the way I'm wired so
hey thanks for the call